sulle mani piccole province inconscio
ma cos'è sta roba bella tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti questo video sono fa vigente
oggi siamo su chiede facto malware sia
poi così gioco starring pimpi da pimp
praticamente ragazzi sarebbe una
versione simile awac your minchia però
un po più [ __ ] molto più figlia perché
se un cazzo di aprono obstacle white boy
un ragazzo bianco vendotutto illustri
bay e poi sbanco vendono che sanno sono
inventata adesso beat disc racca ass
mi devo battere questo couleur 8 il
signor self holiday bischeri prego fare
spaventano per vedere che succede
che bello che è una madonna grosso
grosso gente fa caos my way ma da pac
gli va bene fatto comunque queste sono
scelte che posso fare quindi schiusi
orser poli clean
[Musica]
ok
vabbè bellissimo geniale you fucked up
no aveva bellissimo perché mi sono
permessa fare l'elemosina da cieco tra i
game to see how to drive pd spreca as
vediamo cosa succede
good job and gone round 2 va bene il
primo abbiamo fatti tutti i ragazzi
proviamo un secondo ostacolo spacciatore
di coca kill team uccido
un po esagerato che dici sono morto così
ma perché ma chi cazzo erano due love
you fuck tap tratto nella rapide ci sono
sempre i miei capelli con tanto di
forchetta incastrata bison compito dei
soldi non ci ha dato niente da preso per
il culo ma non è vero
madama che puttanata gli ho fatto ma
cosa hai provato a sniff arti della coca
cola è un genio andiamo avanti ragazzi
quanto a quanto bizzarro ostacolo va
bene prendilo a calci addomestica lo o
mangia lo proviamo mangelo ma no no ma
quando quanto il crudele questo giorno
che cosa cazzo appena visto ok non andrò
mai in cina sono più che convinto di
questo addomestica un ammalato
cos'è sta roba addirittura e vabbè
prendi local ci proviamo l'ultima stato
è imbestialito e lo spacciatore di prima
questo è convinto mi chiede spiaccicato
malissimo che un dottore highline
spiegami che cazzo chi è che ha fatto
questo gioco c'è una persona che ha
fatto questo videogioco chiesto stupra
il dottore uccidi il dottore e prendi la
prescrizione prendi la prescrizione erba
con che faccia perplessa poi fatemelo
rifare uccidi il dottore è stato facile
al good job poter andare così poliziotto
prendi la sua arma taglia i suoi baffi
vediamo come mi dovrei tagliare i baffi
insegnami 0
[Musica]
dopo ci provo io facta prendi la sua
arma da questa che era giusto
e vabbè addirittura un alieno
interdimensionali ping ottieni la
conoscenza perché un tipo così può solo
ottenere la conoscenza vedo teniamo st
conosce bello eh vabbè picchia tipo
indiana jones
non è così contento di aver avuto la
conoscenza credo vedi perché la scuola
fa male acquisisci tecnologia capo del
trasporto fantastico vorrei che siamo
sicuramente in un posto di me è rosa per
il ragno là dietro non è un po più bello
è dio fucked up jackie swide ma perché
devi prendere a cazzotti qualsiasi cosa
che si fa chi è a zero round cioè vale
ma mai distrutto tutto ciao zia [ __ ]
kate da ci colpisce quello schifo aveva
fidanzato di marcia ghiotta ladra mi
chiamo mike tyson è un po più grosso è
vabbè che cosa sei final round a lo devo
pro batteria karate shop iniziative
spaccato un braccio va bene fail
non avevo dubbi sucker punch punt
[Musica]
michael sandwich grandissimo grande ci
siamo si è fatto male ma va bene non
piangere fra nyse moore l'ho battuto non
ce n'è ancora pensavo di averlo battuto
gipsy course spiega
[Musica]
va bene a x cat
sono veramente perplesso ragazzina tanto
l'ha vinto ko ce l'ho fatta ragazzo in
ci credo chiavi e la tipa rimasta lì
fantastica macchina grazie zia che poi
non era neanche così [ __ ] la macchina
che si accende da sola ovviamente io al
clip
credo nella mia vita di non aver vedo
mai giocato a una cosa cosi credit avrà
un ryan captain cosa cazzo hai fumato
zio
la ragazza è stata un'esperienza divina
mi ritengo fortunato di essere un
videogiocatore in questi tempi con
cuochi episodi ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto spero che abbiate imparato come
si nostro che non abbiate imparato un
cazzo sto video trailer i giorni sul
documento è un mi piace ai capace di
facebook del crotone descrizione se ne
siano significativi ci chiamano prossimo
vito di bella ragazza